for the moscow-led security block the
csto its first real military
intervention has been a success
president takayev of kazakhstan told his
counterparts on monday that the
deployment prevented what he called
terrorist groups from taking control of
his country
[Music]
the constitutional order in kazakhstan
has been restored dangerous threats to
the country's security have been
prevented as part of the anti-terrorist
operation work is underway to identify
persons involved in crimes
nationwide protests threatened to unseat
president tokyo
when they turned violent he fired
political rivals including the powerful
ex-president
and called in the csto last wednesday
within 24 hours troops under russian
command were on the ground bolstering
tokyo's authority
vladimir putin has made clear the csto's
longer-term objective
of course we understand that the events
in kazakhstan are not the first and far
from the last attempt at outside
interference in the internal affairs of
our states and the measures taken
clearly showed that we will not allow
such interference so-called color
revolution scenarios to take place
the kazakh authorities say their
so-called counter-terrorism operation is
almost complete around 8 000 people have
been detained so far
but this celebrated kyrgyz musician
beaten into confessing he was a jobless
thug for hire casts doubt on the
official narrative
after a public outcry from kyrgyzstan
he's been freed
there's a consensus among observers that
this crisis has little to do with
international terrorism
i am sure that the clown which lost its
power is behind us
they wanted to regain the power by
violence by overthrowing takayama
life in almaty is returning to a
semblance of normality
but the news on monday that three senior
officers from the security services had
died
two from suicide
raises further questions about what
really is happening inside kazakhstan
robin forrester walker al jazeera